we're living today I think you know
through a mental health crisis where
this meaning and signification the
meaning of someone's life has been
called into question you know they say
that a personal crisis begins when the
story you tell yourself about yourself
is no longer convincing because we are
storytelling creatures and so much of
how we make sense of the world and
Orient ourselves in the world is through
that inner compass that interpretive
framework whether it's Joseph Campbell's
mythological hero structure where we're
a hero on a quest and we're gonna grow
up to be a man or we're gonna achieve a
great thing and slay some dragon and
bring some wisdom back to the Village
because after the Ecstasy the laundry
and its maturity and it's an
interpretive framework that informs our
life with meaning and so on and so forth
so the problem with mental health crises
the problem with the fact that today
more people are dying by so suicide that
are dying from natural disasters and
armed conflict combined according to the
World Health Organization
is that people's inner storytelling has
hit a cry
there's this like negatively
pre-configured inflection point where
like people have lost have lost the plot
they've lost the through line they don't
see a reason to get out of bed in the
morning the LA the world has gone off
the rails there's a sense-making crisis
exacerbated by social media there's a
feeling of alienation and disconnection
there's a meaning crisis an epistemic
crisis and so people are losing their
and they're their inner chatter
their self-defeating thought patterns
have hijacked them there's a there's a
kind of micro stressor
permanent state of being where people
are just increasingly anxious Jamie
wheel says they're stuck in cul-de-sacs
and error messages and all the diseases
of Despair whether it's the depression
or anxiety or PTSD or OCD they're all
stemming from the same thing turns out
the default mode Network this the the
storytelling center of the brains the
seed of the soul the ego it turns out
that when we're in a meaning crisis and
when we've lost our way that can be seen
in fmri scans there's a an over
determined and over developed default
mode Network a kind of tightening a kind
of like gnawing like self-defeating
thought pattern fueled Haze people are
stuck in the Rut it's like it's like
skiing down the same ski routes because
because the because the roots are like
they're like they're like footprinted
they're like they're like cemented you
know it's like there's the grooves we're
stuck in these grooves we're stuck in
these patterns
and it turns out that dissolving these
patterns seems to be the means to
transcend them we have to die so that we
can be reborn and the power of
psychedelics and psychoactivism in
carefully controlled environments with
therapists in the room and carefully
screened patients is that we can evoke a
kind of mystical experience one that
meets the William James questionnaire
people have an experience of the
ineffable they have an experience of
transcendental Bliss they have an
experience of obliteration they have an
experience of death and Resurrection
they have an experience that brings them
back to life it recontextualizes the
self into a marvelous conduit in a
Timeless hole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again as Tim doody wrote and it
turns out we need that because we are
creatures of imagination creatures of
story and creatures of meaning and so we
need meaning we need read story we need
an inner Mythic life that has a bleed
through effect into our biographical
life that informs it so that we feel a
sense of purpose and meaning in our
lives we can live and we can love and
experience passion and Direction and
lean into our dreams but we need that
and it seems like these these transhuman
Technologies these psychedelics they
seem to make it happen we're seeing
we're seeing results in clinical trials
showing that people have one or two of
these mystical experienced psychedelic
sessions they no longer meet the
criteria for PTSD for for for trauma for
anxiety for depression they're brought
back to life through what Chris lessobee
calls knowledge by acquaintance that's
how they work because when you're in the
throngs of Despair knowledge by
description simply will not do you've
got to go there to know there and that's
what psychedelics do psychologically
speaking they pick you up they hurl they
hoist you by your feet and hang you over
the volcanoes of Iceland and you can
suddenly see the world inside out and
upside down and all becomes clear the
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow
and finally through knowledge by
acquaintance you become directly
acquainted somatically and cognitively
an experience of visionary understanding
but also an experience of embodied
cognition because you went there and now
you know there you've had the flash of
Revelation the opiated adjacency and
you've been brought back to life and it
turns out one or two sessions people are
cured
the diseases that are taking more lives
by Suicide the natural disasters or
armed conflict combined cured thanks to
psychedelics
I would say this at least merits a
little more investigation a little more
decriminalization a little more
legalization and a little more inquiry
let's do this let's do this let's do
this
let's do this
[Music]